[Musique]
j'aime pas quitter quand tu fais des
cabris pour être quittait pour trouver
jeu d'actrice sentiment à risque tu fais
tout bourget agissent réfléchi le jem a
changé d'avis
on se disputait entre amis
on s'éloigne et c'est là vite et pas la
plus belle fille de paris a atteint près
de fer tandis numéro tu veux qu'on fasse
du mal quand je veux qu'on soit et quoi
mais ce que du caractère joie les héros
je crois que j'ai trouvé celle qui sera
mon intérêt
or tu vas mourir pour un autre jeune
avait un bas
je me rallie pas à tacos on en est là
pour ta faute
j'aime comme tu parles quand tu passes
la nuit dans mes bras
au monde à prendre ma place
sport d'avoir que tu passes la nuit sous
le bras
ils en ont
on sait pas on répare sur les bars etc
et par me faire rattraper par ma
jalousie
on se bat on s'est cassé la fin je t'ai
pas j'ai voulu essayer
amadou sy
thil moment quand même pas 1000 tentes
où toi et tous ces mecs autour de toi ça
me saoule un gros pourquoi tu regardes
son butcher et viens je t'emmène tu as
ce soir on bouge en vrai je suis dans
mon coeur je suis fragile et instable en
jenner et traverser continues ressort à
la vie en ardèche à café ça arrête un
peu de faire ton numéro je me méfie tous
les ans mais même de mes poteaux j'ai
peur comme nous dos et ça finit ce proto
j'étais pas jaloux jusqu'à ce que je
vois tes photos je sais qu'au fond tu en
as marre non j'ai pas confiance en moi
ça leur fait plaisir tu pars tu sais
qu'à maintenant que ça j'aime comme tu
parles quand tu passes
nuit dans mémoires
battre à ma place
j'espère t'avoir que tu passes la nuit
sous le bras
prendre ma place
on aurait pas assurée par ses quais part
je me faire attraper par ma jalousie
ce pas on s'égare c'est la fin le départ
j'ai beau essayer mais
amadou c
[Musique]